The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
That's why I think that activities
are really important for people.
There's a lot of people that
unfortunately don't engage in activity.
They don't engage and tell him to
have hobbies or anything like that.
I learn a language.
They did do something,
do something that's exciting
art of learning.
You know the problem with
our education system,
Garvey,
I was saying this is what it was,
that we don't have an education
system that teaches you how to think.
We don't like so true.
And that's,
that's,
that's the,
there is an art to learning,
man.
There's an art to learning.
It's an art.
It's an art to be in a human beings.
Right.
It really is.
And no one teaches us.
We don't know what the fuck we're doing.
We're all idiots raising other people
by the same flaws that we were raised
with.
There's no manual for it.
Exactly.
And there's an,
when you look at what we consider our are
our source of education as far as like
what is distributed to us nightly,
what's the news?
Right.
I mean that's really the
education that people have today.
Once you get out of school,
unless you're reading books on your own,
where are you getting your
information about the world?
You're getting it from the fucking news.
Well,
the news doesn't really represent
what's a going on in the world and B,
it doesn't say anything about how
you should be dealing with this,
how you should be thinking,
how we,
how we should resolve these issues.
It's like this tattle tale that just
goes running over and tells us about all
the fucked up shit that's
happening in the world,
but they don't,
there's not a dialogue with a person.
It's like a source of information
shy.
The way that that complaint
goes back at least 3,500 years.
Socrates,
when he was in his trial said,
you take a,
you wouldn't take a horse to
try to ride it and not train it.
The same applies to a human being.
You got to,
you got to start with,
with the notion of he was trying to
teach philosophy in the sense that you
better,
you better know what questions
to ask throughout your life.
And we should start with young people,
educate young people the right
way with the right questions.
If you don't do that,
then,
then you know,
you've got to start with a base almost,
you know,
and,
and uh,
we don't,
we don't do that.
Men,
we,
it's,
it's almost like learning Jujitsu,
just learning moves without learning
the principles behind it first.
Yeah.
Well it's also like learning
Jujitsu without going over
the real correct drills,
learning real live applications and,
and the,
you know,
the,
the way school is set up,
I,
you note again,
you mother Fucker,
the way school is set up,
it's,
they have x amount of thousand kids and
they have to get these kids through with
a basic understanding of the
building blocks of our world.
They have to understand math.
They,
I've done understanding of how to
structure a sentence and they understand.
They have to understand that if foreign
paragraphs and they've got to know what
happened in the past and then you're,
you're off on your own,
good luck fucker,
stop college.
Um,
I,
I saw quite a few of your videos online.
It really a really,
really interesting conversations.
And one of them that really struck me was,
um,
you will live with several
of them that struck me,
but one of them was your
story of being mugged and you,
you told people on an online room like
where you got mugged and people were
upset that you in telling
them that you got,
didn't telling the world
that you got mugged there,
it was lowering their property value.
Yeah.
That was,
it was a bad one.
Um,
that's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean it was one thing to get mugged.
It was just Kinda freaky in itself.
Uh,
you know,
and whatever,
shaming weirdness goes with that.
But,
um,
I guess what I was trying to do,
I mean deep down was probably elicit,
you know,
love and affection from people on my list,
so I put up,
Oh,
you know,
and there was a social,
something social responsibility to it.
So I put up where I got mugged cause
everyone should know this is maybe a
dangerous stretch here.
We got to maybe get a light.
But um,
yeah,
so I sent,
I sent it out and then,
um,
the first two emails I got back from
this like loving list of parents was how
dare you see exactly where it happened.
You know,
we live right across the street,
you know,
you're going to lower our property
values and like are you selling now?
Is that,
is that now we're not selling.
But it was a really weird time when people
needed their property values to go up
because they were trying to get bigger
mortgages and pay down and do all that.
Um,
and it was just like so
panicky there about that,
that some,
you know,
someone was afraid of,
what if a newspaper
covers it and it's bad.
And what if I,
it's so weird when one's
and zero's Trump humanity,
you know.
And in that case,
that's exactly what that is.
It's ones and Zeros.
Trump,
humanity.
Well yeah,
in two kinds of ones and Zeros,
you know the,
the ones and zeroes,
that money.
Yeah,
no.
And the ones and Zeros,
it's sort of of digital technology,
which I think can create
a kind of a distance
feeling.
The impact of saying that to
someone's face that you're,
yeah,
there's a weird communication
that takes place online.
That's you.
It doesn't have any consequence.
You know,
you can,
you can do it anonymously
and this is this,
it's like these barbs that you can
just send out and illogically like in,
in,
in ways that you would never,
if you had to deal with someone one on
one because you would feel it and you
would look at them,
you would feel their response.
You would be like,
why are you saying this?
Like,
like why?
Why are you being such an asshole?
But because you are anonymous,
you can just,
so people are just like in this
unnatural communication thing.
Right?
But then the,
the,
the part that,
that worries me after that is if you
get used to doing it like that in an
anonymous way online,
does that start to make the behavior a
bit more normative when you're even with
your identity?
Oh,
I guarantee it has to.
It has to.
There's,
there's no free rides
when it comes to that.
I really feel like your thoughts,
you're kind of like,
there was always a thing.
I remember when I was in high school,
this was someone in my school newspaper
wrote like a funny critique about the
boy scouts.
And one of the things that he didn't
like about the boy scouts was that they
wanted you to keep your thoughts pure.
And he was like,
you know,
well,
my thoughts are my own thoughts.
You know,
I'm just,
as long as I don't do anything,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with my thoughts.
All right.
Know if that was really smartly argued.
I remember reading that going,
wow,
this kid's pretty clever.
But then I thought about it.
I'm like,
but you,
if you're thinking about creepy shit,
you probably are kind of creepy.
You know,
and it's,
it's not going to get any better.
Just,
you know,
you're just going to eventually one day
going to snap and then you got to do
something.
He'd be thing.
Yeah.
If you really are like the,
I don't know.
I mean everyone has their own
definition of thoughts being pure,
you know,
like a more lenient person might allow
a lot of like healthy sexual things and
the idea of thoughts being pure
as long as it's not creepy,
but there's other people that
would just sit around and say,
well,
let me just think about creepy shit
all day and not do it and I'm fine,
but they're not,
there's no free ride.
There may be though,
you think.
Well,
I mean,
what you're describing,
what you're describing is,
you know,
the benefits of an absolute police
state as long as it was always right.
Yeah.
That's no problem.
That's the problem.
I mean,
you can always get your minority report,
you know,
just in case maybe they're wrong.
I really subscribing to that.
I'm just saying that
you really can be nice.
You can't have really shitty
thoughts and get through.
And I think that if you're
really shitty online,
you have those thoughts.
Even if it's only online,
I really believe that negative
energy is going to leak.
Genuinely shitty.
I mean,
it's just how do you decide what's,
what's,
what's shitty and whatnot.
But yeah,
no,
it's people when their demeanor,
you are online without your face.
The meaning you can be online with your
face on the meaner you can get in real
life,
you know,
until you just got mean people.
Okay.
You ready to,
of course recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?